we've all had shows that didn't go the
way we planned so have you ever had a
show that you were like oh no like
something bad happened so the Menzel
girls we have weak letters even before
childbirth so like when you pee or maybe
like jogging up laugh like you laugh
yeah and then
when you're laughing and then if you're
singing a lot you know you're drinking a
lot of water so um if something happens
to me on stage really funny that takes
me by surprise I just know there's no
way and I've I've peed and then my
wonderful friend Joby Horgan who is my
dresser for All Broadway shows she's
once I had black tights opaque black
tights on underneath the big gown I peed
in them and the touch just sapped it all
up and then I got off stage and I was
like jealous and I handed my friend who
I love so much who does not deserve to
take urine filled tights to the dude but
Candace is right back here my stylist
like she is laughing right now the
things that have happened in quick
changes
she's my best friend and I would do
anything for her especially because she
handled my urine stains yeah but um and
then I went back out command no and I
sang Defying Gravity you know
oh my God
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's amazing that that was the song
speaking of in person Broadway is back
so Broadway
I know they have to be excited
everyone's been out of work so there's
that but also just the creativity I feel
like that is like the the lifeline of
New York like it's like the blood flow
for me yeah we're all like Tinker Bell
and Peter Pan we need Applause to live
yeah and and our and our cast members
were were waiting for a year and a half
to be back up on that stage and and I
gotta say not only is Hamilton back it's
never been a better time to see a
Broadway show because even the
long-running shows have now had a
rehearsal process they had to start from
scratch and put their shows back up
again so I was at the reopening of
phantom yes a couple weeks ago and it
was just like unbelievable wait I heard
that he Andrew Lloyd Webber DJ'd after
did you see that yeah sure eventually I
think that that's amazing Al dubs on the
one and twos when we left the show
DJ aldubs
so anyway you are a substitute teacher I
didn't know that as well yeah my first
job out of college was teaching seventh
grade English at my old high school and
yeah it was amazing what was like your
favorite thing to teach my favorite
thing to teach was Shakespeare uh we
would teach A Midsummer Night's Dream
and they were into it yeah because the
thing is Shakespeare is really boring
when you have to read it but if you have
to act it it's like oh you were a cool
teacher I was kind of a cool teacher and
I would I had um you know everyone would
pick their names out who they were
playing that day and girls play boys and
boys and you acted out and then acting
it out you understand it like like
English drama class yeah that was really
it was really fun and I you know they
offered me a full-time job and I could
and I loved it I truly loved teaching
and so I could see the Mr Holland's Opus
version of my life of like I'll be here
30 years and I'll inspire a lot of kids
and I'll never finish my play and so I
ran and so I basically was like I can't
teach full time I'm writing the show in
the Heights so I was a professional
substitute teacher turn wow I was
basically a sub at my old high school
until in the heights but you bet on
yourself you bet on yourself I did I did
and weirdly
um my future brother-in-law was one of
my students
um what your life is weird wait what
yeah he was um he was a he was still a
junior when I was subbing and then when
I started dating uh my wife he turns to
his sister and goes you're dating Mr
Miranda
from school
and now he's my brother
oh my God that's what a small world
the musical features songs written by
Max Martin including since you've been
gone Lorna is excellent I love singing
with you oh y'all gotta check that out
so Laura how's the show going the show
is going amazing Kelly thank you so much
for asking absolutely this is a really
exciting time because it is Tony Awards
season yeah yeah so come on out it's a
party every single night on Broadway
come to New York and see us and there's
so many hits
that show is like I don't think people
realize how much Max Martin has done
like in his career so it's it's an
incredible amount of hits that you're
gonna know when you go see the show
thank you so much Lauren I enjoyed
singing with you thank you
yeah
meet Cynthia have y'all remember I have
not but I'm a huge fan you were very
popular at my house my wife is a huge
musical theater fan and my daughter is a
musical theater Prodigy and she showed
me your performance at the Tony's which
the consensus and the polono household
is it's the best Tony performance ever
for college
[Applause]
somewhere
she is don't let the principal watch
this you have the coolest dad ever I
would never let my kids skip school
I'm a teacher's daughter it's got to be
something really good um that's amazing
though so you love to you'd love to do
musical theater yeah oh my gosh that's
amazing what's your favorite musical
like what's your what was like oh my
gosh oh that was the first one I ever
saw
um oh okay probably the first musical I
ever saw and I was like oh my gosh was I
saw Hamilton with my mom with the
original Broadway cast and it was just
like the most amazing thing I've ever
seen in my entire life so what advice
would you give to someone so young that
wants to do musical theater um have fun
first of all is what I say and I'm I
guess make sure you pick the shows that
you really want to be in because those
shows you're in the eight shows a week
six days a week for sure that's
commitment yeah you gotta love it if you
don't love it when you read the script
this don't do it okay even if you're
like playing a small character you've
got to still love it because you want to
be there with everybody all the energy
you know means something enjoy it really
really enjoy it I want to ask you this
because you've done so much Broadway
um that you've forgotten your lyrics
right I've heard that you kind of did it
on stage and people think it's kind of a
fun thing with you right yeah well it's
not
it's not a fun thing I I'm bad at it
nightmare it's I know I'm bad at it too
are you how are you at it though because
here's my
how rhyme it won't make sense but it
will somehow rhyme so that's what you're
taught to do what's interesting is I did
not do that
I took the opposite approach and forgot
the human language forgot the entirety
of our experience vocally as a
collective species
and just stopped talking as the music
was playing very loudly it gets worse
this stage manager was screaming the
line at me going you're making things up
again
and all I heard was
what I had like tinnitus or so I was a
living oh you had like a ringing I had
like a ringing sensation I've had that
happen when it was like it was like
energy up above got bored that day and
was like let's play with Josh's life and
it was like this is insane and then my
co-star was screaming the line at me and
I still couldn't say the line I couldn't
hear anything and then can I curse on
your show well believe me you'll bleep
it out good this is how I got out of it
okay Live Theater people paying 500 a
ticket to see Book of Mormon I looked
out at my cast and said what's my next
line
I
I'm trained professional
don't try that anymore
if I'm at that show best experience ever
right but here's here's the worst part
they they were so confused they weren't
even enjoying it they were just like
this is this is a very weird part of
this show right now does this happen
every night this script feels like it
needs work and from that point on in
Book of Mormon I actually in the song I
had an actual Book of Mormon where I
pasted the lines so that when I opened
it up I don't care now I did it 10 years
ago whatever whatever you sought after
the fact
I also wanted to bring this up too
because um our friend Ariana Grande
she's playing you and Glinda yeah it's
Glinda and and wicked
Wicked did she call you for advice like
have y'all talked
she didn't call me for advice she was
really nervous she said I want to pay
homage to you but I'm scared I don't
want you I don't I want to make you have
proud I go wait you've already made me
proud so it doesn't matter yeah check
done that that's achieved that's
achieved
um what I want to encourage you to do
Ariana is make Glenda York Linda sure
you can tap tip your hat at me if you
want but really I just want you to do
you I don't know why I'm so emotional
today because I noticed since she was
10. I was gonna say yeah because you
noticed your little videos and now I see
them and you know the full circle for
her I found I was with her when she
found out and she was crying there was a
cake for her she was like it was like
one of her biggest dreams and she called
me she said oh my God I was like yeah
and we sound like dolphins
I did
what I mean it's just two dolphins
talking but I'm so proud of her and she
calls me and she said this is what I got
to do today and what do you think of
that I'm just I'm just so proud of her I
can't wait to see her do it I know it's
gonna be like an out of body experience
for you though it is just bringing that
role to life you know I can't wait I
love the original I'm excited to see
what they're going to do with the
character because they've they've lived
for so long so it's going to be exciting
to see I know and I just love that it's
it's Ariana and like what you mean to
her and what it means it's just a really
cool thing when something like that
happens in life and it's special and she
appreciates it she does yeah she does
and she'll she just said I'm gonna be
freaking out Kristen I'm gonna be
freaking out the bat of the premiere
maybe
she'll do the accent she's like I'm
really scared I'm like shut up I'm like
stop you're gonna be great like my
boyfriend's like YouTube why did your
voice change with her yes is it true
that when you won I just found this out
that when you were nominated for your
first Tony Award you didn't even know
what a Tony was no no that's that's true
story you know the Tony Awards are the
big prestigious uh award that they give
every year yeah and you know I got in
this business for work you know I wanted
a job and I didn't go following award
shows or things that nature so I'm doing
Jesus Christ Superstar and the knob
comes on the door and the guy says Mr
Marine you have an envelope I said give
me the envelope it goes like this I said
give me the envelope May says no this is
the envelope I said yeah
yeah I mean below
I'm reading it right and I'm realizing
it's from a guy named Tony
so I turned this guy and I go
who's Tony
and why does he love me so much then I
read it and found out these are my peers
who said you got something a matter of
fact I have the letter today there's
tears
because you get it that you know you're
in this but you don't think about it
because we do it because we love what we
do yeah you know you know and you're
just hustling your thing you're doing
your thing and then somebody says hey
you got something now this kid from
Brooklyn I was like wow they like me oh
that it is cool it's it's not about the
awards I always say that like it's not
about it but it is validating to like
you know do all this hard work and then
somebody be like that was pretty good
yeah that's nice yeah your peers saying
yeah you got something there did you
always want to do Broadway were you
always uh I wanted to do employment
me too yeah yeah I was looking to pay
that electric bill I really didn't
set out and not beginning to do broad
way because I didn't know what Broadway
was all about I'm this Kid From Brooklyn
running around the streets you know
learning how to dance running from the
cops you know
um it's a difference and
um somebody said to me one day you why
don't you go to the high school for
Performing Arts and I said okay cool
they said where is it it says it's in
Manhattan in those days you said
Manhattan I thought I needed a passport
to get over to Manhattan I mean I was
like oh okay now go to school and I see
dances for the first time and I was like
wow
wow there's another world out here it's
called the Arts and it's called
opportunity too for kids that love the
Arts you know that's a great opportunity
you know every kid gets lots of great
people to teach me and learn from some
fantastic woman named um Dr Rachel Yocum
was the principal of the dance
Department she saw me there with all
these dancers and I was just sitting
there with my my Bermuda shorts on and
my U.S kids sneakers my t-shirt a little
skinny brim hat you know sitting made up
a little dance to kill a Joe by Quincy
Jones I'm sitting here get up do my
little dancing I get up in front of the
people and I do my little dad
I thought it was very cool right but I
didn't know the people sitting at the
table or people like Martha Graham and
George Balanchine and all the girls
sometimes ignorance is blessed I didn't
know what they were they were just a
bunch of white people yeah
doing my thing you know you said how'd
you do I said did I hate she said what's
your name I said Benjamin she said what
I said Benjamin she said you mean
Benjamin I said yeah Benjamin what's
wrong with you do you hear me
he said would you like to go to school I
said hi
I here I am folks I love that hey I know
you do like many other things but do
people still freak out like my thing is
like everybody comes up and yells nah
Kelly Clarkson do people this is your
Hamilton so it's like do people always
come up to you and are just like talking
Non-Stop about Hamilton because it was
such a movement I feel like when I was a
kid and rant came out how popular that
was now it blew up that's what Hamilton
is for this generation it's just like
enormous it was that and it no it was
weird you know David used to say this
thing this I love that David used to say
right outside the stage door you were a
beetle for a block you know what I mean
like once you crossed 8th Avenue it kind
of died down but at the it took it took
time to get used to getting recognized
at the airport and stuff like that I was
I'd be looking behind me like who were
they looking at yeah
um but um it was you know a huge
phenomenon a change star lives yeah the
trajectory yeah
you've done the biggest show on Broadway
literally but what was your first
theater role do you remember my very
first theater role was in kindergarten I
played Martin Luther King in our black
history yes that's where I started at
the top yeah uh all downhill from there
I know I played Martin Luther King in
our black history you know ceremony and
um I took it very very seriously
um the teacher
um Miss Lewis you know she was she was
really kind to the kids it was like she
wanted you to memorize it but if you
didn't it was okay she would like sit
next to you and meld the words right
before you had to say them because
you're like five right yeah but I knew
all my lines all five of mine
[Applause]
yeah okay nothing yes this is just one
of the many reasons I should never be an
actor but yes but I
but I'm like how you all memorize
because I did musical theater growing up
and I I would almost like I mean sweaty
pits my stomach would hurt like I was
just memorizing that I I retained pretty
well I still might remember some of it I
mean I think it was something like you
know
Martin Luther King had a dream something
like that uh was pretty nice
I think everyone
that's amazing I love you she was a
singer first yes when she was younger
and when she whips that out it's it's
the best when we get to see like Mamma
Mia or into the woods in the woods yeah
it's amazing but yeah she I did like two
scenes with her in that movie I was just
too terrified the whole time to even
really like take her in I mean but then
she came to see um dear Evan Hansen
which was a show that I was doing in New
York
my gosh like she came to see you were
you so nervous completely like I added
like an extra voice lesson that week
like a new haircut like I really oh my
God I got prepared because I got warning
that she was coming so I I would not
want to know oh I have to know but
anyway who else would be also being at
your shows
that's how everybody kind of started
coming through we had Hillary Clinton we
had like uh Beyonce came I mean
what do you do at that point oh no
Me Slowly passing away
just completely she like you're like
yeah yeah I mean it was like an aliens
and a lot of people yeah she is and now
you like saw her that's another example
where I really wanted to know she was
there because I'm looking in the
audience and you see just like the shape
of her weave yeah just like if I had
spotted that I think I would have just
passed out so I was happy to know
exactly where she was going to be and
that she was coming
yeah God for 20 years yeah Leading Lady
In The West End of London and on
Broadway and um yeah
I mean do you you miss it it's a lot of
work Kelly my God as a as a singer yeah
if somebody said to me and you know I
don't mind who I admit it to if somebody
said you can never act again under the
singing sing again there would be no
competition singing is in my bloodstream
it's my catharsis it's in my soul and I
miss it terribly but this show but you
seems like getting me to do both I know
I was gonna say you said it's a purple
club owner
I know the karaoke thing and then the
Christmas yeah you've sung on the show
yeah Sing Sing song yeah sorry mom
um yes son sure and we all sing here
that's actually amazing I mean kinda I'm
not singing on any West End stages
I'm not singing on West End either
but is it true that you're going back to
Broadway soon I am yeah I was I was
doing a play right before the shutdown
and we were about to open but we're very
very lucky uh the plays American buffalo
which is a pretty famous American play
and it's just three guys one room I feel
bad for the shows that are much bigger
and didn't get to sustained because
they're can we talk about the cast yeah
we got uh Sam Rockwell and Lawrence fish
first yeah they really got some d-level
people in there where they asked three
Knuckleheads oh my gosh that cast is
incredible yeah this is so good I'm very
excited and again we're very very lucky
because we did lose a lot of Broadway
shows over the pandemic so we'll be back
and it's crazy it's just like the
Avengers Thanos snap we literally are
opening like the same day two years
later so it's like okay I guess it's now
2022 but we're very very fortunate so
you'll have to come see the play if
you're into seeing three guys yell at
each other if you're into seeing three
incredible people on stage yeah I love
the cats it's so good and I also love
that you use Thanos in this interview
I know I'm just really into Marvel but
whatever we're good I feel like that
you're demographic yeah it is it's me
it's my my demographic is what I was
concerned about next week
by Idina Menzel Talia was so stoked when
she first found out she decided to
surprise her vocal coach with the news
in a video that's since gone viral and
you'll see why take a look I'm gonna be
Elphaba on Broadway
oh yeah I told you when you were 12. I
know you did
oh my God I'm so happy for you thank you
you're gonna have to come to New York oh
I will now for sure
[Applause]
we had to bring them on please welcome
Talia and her vocal coach Craig Wick
y'all give it up
I love you
love them meet the girls
I'm huge fans with you all
congratulations wow congratulations
we'll be seeing you it's a very musical
show thus far yes I love this well
congrats on the new role it's kind of a
new role I mean you've been in the role
for a while but it's now you're on
Broadway in the role yes yeah yeah which
is wild I mean this is really a dream
come true for me I saw the show when I
was nine on Broadway that's how long the
show's been around yeah I was always
into musical theater and always very
theatrically inclined and started taking
voice lessons with this guy here Craig
Wick way to go Chris
and when I was like 12 years old we
started singing the music from Wicked
and um he told me you're going to do
this role on Broadway someday and I kind
of held that dream in my heart and with
a lot of hard work went to college
musical theater and started playing the
role on the national tour of wicked
um summer of 2019 and wow obviously we
had a pandemic in between but some
things happened yeah some things
happened and uh life shut down life shut
down and yeah so you were surprised but
you kind of weren't because you kind of
knew she was gonna always do this well
Talia came to me like most young girls
they're pressing their voice to produce
these belt sounds and we had to take the
pressure off yeah get her because
what happened was she had this
phenomenal operatic voice which most
people don't understand she could be an
operatic star at the Met those are the
best singers that are able to do that
yeah yeah then once you stabilize that
larynx then you just adjust the
different harmonics so she took two at
the Belterra twos to the second third
and fourth harmonics which figure that
out
she was brilliant and she we did we did
a Defying Gravity one day in the studio
and I just looked at my jaw dropped I
said you were going to do this on
Broadway but I knew it I knew I knew it
I was I've told the story to many people
thousands of times and then I knew it
she knew it I love that well y'all seen
Wicked obviously yeah well I don't know
you haven't seen Bridge again yet
maybe you're a little late
stuff for us okay Barlow and bear I see
you down there
um that was amazing um well I am not the
only one um who's totally moved by
talia's video there's someone backstage
who wants to wish her good luck on her
Broadway debut so will that person come
out
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
I just missed you at the Gershwin by
like a week a couple weeks and I'll come
back I'll come back I know I brought all
those smelly prepubes
and then you missed that I'm so happy
for you and the advice that I would give
or that Kelly might give as well is make
sure you wear the black opaque tights
underneath you got it just in case
you're drinking a lot of water and
someone makes you laugh and you have a
and you pee in your mouth it stops it up
really good okay good let's go right out
there and fly oh no worries can I just
say the amount of times I have like sung
to you in my car it's just like it's
crazy I'm just gonna hang out with you
I love that her whole body turned
towards you like oh no no no no
I'm just gonna come join you because
Chris is like you're out there on an
island
no I gotta say I gotta ask her do you
remember your first time like when you
heard you got the roll oh my God yeah
you didn't actually know the gravity
yeah I didn't even mean to do it you
didn't actually even know that you keep
your posture to face
I was messing with you um no do you
remember that moment you know because
you didn't know how big it was gonna be
you didn't know what was going on oh my
God I yeah no it was incredible we
didn't know what it was going to be it
was different but I just remember
auditioning and working on it with my
ex-husband actually who was my best
friend and was learning to find gravity
and I just knew I said this is something
it just made me want to cry when I was
practicing at home and and then when I
got it I just I felt like yeah it was
you just know when you're going to be a
part of something you don't know how big
it's going to be or whatever but yeah
I'm so just glad that you're here and
and you're and you're gonna extend that
what am I trying to say
no you know what it's such a big role
right do you ever do you feel pressure
there's been some elphibos right do you
ever feel it pressure or you know what
you should do you feel like you have
huge foots
what I actually feel is the strength of
all of the women that have played the
part before me okay optimism I like you
it's true I get
[Applause]
Peter expecting you know to to hear the
cast album and I'm I'm never going to be
this incredible person right here but I
can be me and I walk in the footsteps of
all these incredible women that have
played this part and bring their unique
strength to this right it's just
incredible so yeah
[Music]
all right
I'm going
[Music]